>> John: FROM FIRST!
>> Garry: FROM A VERY,
VERY POOR ANGLE AND LAYS IT ON
PUCK
AND HE SNAPS OSHIE.
OSHIE COMES IN AND CAUSES THE
MANTHA, SHOT SCORES.ERE BY MANT.
THE BACKHAND, LITTLE 6 INCHES
OFF T
IGHT BE PART AND PARSE
HE WAITED OUT
DRAKE BATHERSON WHO WAS SLIDING
IN FRONT TO
>>
PUCK.
HE KNOWS HE IS GOING TO NORRIS.
IT'S JUST A MATTER.
OTTAWA IS SEAM PASS.
NO CHANCE IT!
NORRIS GETS IN ON THE PUCK.
TKACHUK GETS HIS SKATES AGAINST
THE BOARDS.NUMBER 736 FOR ALEX
OVECHKIN AND THE CAPITALS GET
THE LEADT DOWN AND
ONCE HE IS HUNTING THE PUCK DOWN
AND ALL HE IS LOOKING AT IS HIMD
THE CAPITALS MAKE IT
GET INTO THE DIRTY AREA.
THERE WAS AN OFF.
KUZNETSOV UP THROUGH CENTRE.
INTO TNIEL SPRONG.
TURNS IT OVER.
FORMENTON TRYING TO SPLIT HIS
WAYCK AND OTTAWA
MAYBE OFF THE STICK OF ORLOV AND
ALEX OVECHKIN, SECOND OF THE ANS
JUST A SNAPSHOT UPSTAIRIR